With Avengers: Age Of Ultron out on Blu-ray
& DVD now, let’s take a look at the 50 of
the best Easter Eggs and references found
in the second Avengers outing.
If you haven’t seen Age Of Ultron yet, just
be aware there are spoilers ahead for the
film and future Marvel movies.
In Age of Ultron, Captain America’s shield
has been upgraded with magnetic elements so
he can call it back to him.
Avengers comics from the early 60s also show
Tony Stark upgraded Cap’s shield in a similar
manner.
The new shield also echoes Stark’s ability
to call his Iron Man suits to him, as we saw
in Iron Man 3, and after Loki pushed him out
of Stark Tower in The Avengers movie.
During Captain America’s face-off with Ultron
on top of a speeding truck, there’s a nice
nod to the late 1970s Captain America TV movies
starring Reb Brown.
In Age Of Ultron, Cap’s shield falls down
to the road where Black Widow scoops it up
and places it on the front of her motorbike,
echoing the look of Reb Brown’s 70s bike
which featured a round windshield reminiscent
of Cap’s shield.
During the Avengers’ attack on Strucker’s
Hydra Base, Thor hits Captain America’s
shield with his hammer, creating a sonic shockwave
that knocks their enemies on their asses and
takes out their tank.
This is a cool call-back with a twist to The
Avengers movie where The Asgardian god and
the US super-soldier first saw the effect
of their hammer and shield combo in the movies.
However, that time they were on opposing sides
in an argument over Loki, and Cap demanded
Thor put down his hammer… which he did as
he flew through the air, smashing it into
Cap’s vibranium shield, causing a shockwave
that razed the forest around them!
For more on Cap’s shield and all things
Avengers, check out my video 12 Things You
Didn’t Know About the Avengers: Age Of Ultron.
The epic slow-mo shot that shows the Avengers
in mid-air poses as they attack Strucker’s
men during their raid of his Hydra Research
Base in Sokovia feels like something that
could have been torn straight from the pages
of a comic book.
Director Joss Whedon said that what he wants
to say with that shot that is, “Here’s
a comic book movie, and here’s the feeling
that you came to get.”’
When Tony Stark enters the HYDRA base, he
discovers the remains of a Leviathan, one
of the enormous beasts used as alien warships
during the Battle of New York in the first
Avengers movie.
Joss Whedon and Zak Penn created the Leviathans
especially for the Marvel Cinematic Universe,
however, the word Leviathan does crop up elsewhere
in the comics and in Agent Carter as the name
of a secret Soviet organisation.
Tony Stark’s dark vision of the Avengers
defeated reminds me of the nightmares he had
in Iron Man 3 following the PTSD he suffered
after the Battle Of New York.
Stan Lee couldn’t budge Thor’s hammer
in the first Thor movie, and in Age Of Ultron
he couldn’t keep up with Thor’s drinking
either!
Playing a World War 2 veteran, Lee tries to
prove Thor wrong that his special Asgardian
liquor is ‘not meant for mortal men’,
but he ends up sozzled, slurring his catchphrase
Excelsior, which is Latin for ‘Ever Upward’
and is also the state motto of New York.
New York-born Lee has used the phrase Excelsior
repeatedly over the years in his columns for
Marvel comics and in the title of his autobiography.
The liquor Thor says mortals can’t handle
‘was aged for a thousand years in the barrels
built from the wreck of Brunnhilde’s fleet.’
Brunnhilde is a character in Marvel’s comics.
She was picked by Thor’s father Odin to
lead a host of warrior goddesses known as
Valkyrior.
Brunnhilde was considered as a potential character
for Thor: The Dark World, though didn’t
make the cut.
Perhaps this mention is a sign we’ll see
her in Thor: Ragnarok, a storyline that includes
Brunnhilde in the comics.
During the Avengers’ party, Anthony Mackie’s
character Sam Wilson, aka Falcon, tells Captain
America that he’s ‘happy chasing cold
leads on our missing person’s case.’
Which is a reference to Cap’s best friend
and fellow army man Bucky Barnes, who became
the Winter Soldier assassin after experiments
by Hydra, and then disappeared after saving
Cap at the end of the second Captain America
movie.
Last time we saw Bucky, he was at the Smithsonian
Museum, dressed in civilian clothes and looking
at the ‘Bucky Barnes’ display in the Captain
America exhibit.
During the Avengers’ after-party, when Steve
Rogers tries to lift Thor’s hammer, he can’t
quite manage it but he does move it a little.
Which is a nod to the comic books where Cap
has been deemed worthy to lift the Asgardian
god’s hammer, for example, in issue 390
of The Mighty Thor back in 1988.
And in the movie when Natasha Romanov refuses
to take her turn to lift the hammer, her remark
‘that’s not a question I need answered’,
is a sly allusion to the fact that Black Widow
already proved herself worthy of wielding
Thor’s hammer in issue 3 of the 2014 comic
book mini-series What If? Age Of Ultron.
At the end of Age Of Ultron, Captain America
wonders if Thor left his hammer in an elevator
and the elevator moved whether that would
mean the elevator was worthy. Thor laughs
this off.
But that little exchange recalls the funny
moment in Thor: The Dark World where the Asgardian
god hung his hammer on a coat hook in Jane’s
apartment.
Just before the Avengers have their visions,
Thor warns Captain America that Scarlet Witch
has tried to warp his mind, and tells him,
‘Take special care, I doubt a human could
keep her at bay. Fortunately, I am mighty.’
Which is a nice nod to the title of The Mighty
Thor comics as well as the 1960s animated
TV series of the same name!
When Ultron first becomes conscious and starts
trawling for information, we see various images
from other Marvel movies, including one of
Tony Stark from the beginning of the first
Iron Man movie.
While Black Widow goes for her gun during
the Avengers’ first face-off with Ultron,
Tony Stark grabs a fondue fork to battle Ultron’s
bots.
That fondue fork is a playful nod to the movie
Captain America: The First Avenger where Tony’s
father Howard Stark says to Peggy Carter,
‘I thought we could stop off in Lucerne
for a late-night fondue.’
Which leads Cap to awkwardly ask Peggy, ‘So,
are you two… do you… fondue?’
When Ultron first appears to the Avengers,
he makes several references in his speech
to strings and puppets.
Then after Thor smashes him with his hammer,
we hear Ultron sing his very creepy version
of a few lines from the song “I’ve Got
Not Strings”, which featured in the 1940
Disney animated film Pinocchio, about a wooden
puppet who becomes a real boy. And we even
hear a little clip from the original version
of the song.
When Ultron first speaks to Scarlet Witch
and Quicksilver, he’s wearing a red cloak,
which is a reference to his identity in the
comics as the Crimson Cowl.
When Ultron tells Scarlett Witch and Quicksilver
that ‘invaders create avengers’, it’s
a nod to the comic-book superhero team The
Invaders, which was co-created by Roy Thomas,
and whose original line-up included Captain
America, Bucky Barnes, and the Sub-Mariner.
Black Widow’s vision of the Red Room gives
us an insight into the painful process that
made her the character we know today, and
through her Graduation Ceremony also provides
a link with Bruce Banner who can’t have
children either.
Natasha’s Red Room vision is a nod to both
Marvel’s comics and the TV series Agent
Carter and their Soviet espionage training
programme which turns young girls into super-spies.
The film’s ballet scenes refer back to the
Black Widow’s origins in the comic books
where, depending on the story arc, she either
trained as a ballerina or was implanted with
false memories to think she was one.
As for Natasha’s enforced sterilisation,
that’s a nod to writer Richard K Morgan’s
Black Widow mini-series.
During Captain America’s vision, he sees
Peggy Carter in a Second World War ballroom,
and she asks him ‘Are you ready for our
dance?’, after which we see them briefly
dance together.
This recalls the scene in Captain America:
The Winter Soldier when Cap visited an elderly
Peggy in her retirement home.
Peggy was taken aback to see him after so
many years, to which Cap replied, ‘Well,
I couldn’t leave my best girl. Not when
she owes me a dance.’
Also in the dancehall where Cap’s vision
takes place, there’s a band playing called
the Roy Thomas Players.
Roy Thomas is a comic book writer and was
Editor-In-Chief of Marvel Comics after Stan
Lee in the 1970s.
Thomas co-created many Marvel characters including
Ultron, Vision, and Iron Fist.
Thor’s vision set us up for the next Thor
solo movie, Ragnarok.
In Norse mythology, Ragnarok means the doom
or twilight of the gods, and it’s also an
apocalyptic event in the comics that results
in numerous significant deaths and the destruction
of Asgard.
By the way, in the comics, Ragnarok is also
the name of a Thor clone co-created by Tony
Stark from a strand of the Asgardian god’s
hair.
Which is interesting because in Age Of Ultron,
after Stark fails to lift Thor’s enchanted
hammer, he suggests the handle is imprinted
with a security code matched to Thor’s fingerprints.
So, according Stark’s logic, anyone with
Thor’s fingerprints could wield it. For
example, a clone!
Age Of Ultron marks the fifth film where an
MCU character has grabbed Tony Stark by the
throat.
In the first Avengers movie it was Loki who
did it, in Iron Man 3 it was Guy Pearce’s
character Aldrich Killian, in Iron Man 2 it
was Black Widow, and in Iron Man it was Jeff
Bridges’ character Obadiah Stane.
This time it’s Thor who gets to grips with
Stark’s jugular, and Ultron has a go too!
But, Stark isn’t the only Avenger to get
throttled in this movie: Thor gets similar
treatment at the hands of Ultron as does Vision,
and Captain America, not only gets it from
Ultron but also two of his drones!
And that isn’t all: The Hulk also gets it
in the neck from Iron Man in his Hulkbuster
suit. While, in his vision, Thor gets choked
by Heimdall.
Joss Whedon has said he gave the name Veronica
to Tony Stark’s new armour system which
deploys the Hulkbuster suit via satellite
because Veronica is the opposite of Betty.
Betty is Bruce Banner’s love interest in
the comics and The Incredible Hulk movie.
And the Veronica Whedon refers to is likely
Veronica Lodge from Archie Comics who is a
rival to Archie’s girlfriend who also happens
to be called Betty!
It’s possible that Stark’s new armour
system Veronica is also a nod to a Marvel
comics character called Veronica Benning,
a physical therapist employed by Stark Enterprises.
Veronica Benning helps Tony Stark recover
use of one of his hands, which is interesting
as in Age of Ultron, the Veronica system replaces
Tony Stark’s damaged Hulkbuster arm.
In The Avengers, Loki was locked up in a steel
and glass cage built to contain the Hulk in
case he became a problem on board the helicarrier.
Although that cage was never used for the
Hulk, in Age Of Ultron Veronica traps him
in another metal cage during the Hulkbuster
scene.
Interestingly, neither Loki nor the Hulk could
be contained by either cage.
When Iron Man tries to calm down the Hulk
during the Hulkbuster sequence, he mentions
Bruce Banner, which only makes the Hulk angrier.
However, Iron Man realises what he’s done
and says to himself, ‘Right! Don’t mention
puny Banner!’
Which is a call-back to the comic books and
the Hulk’s catchphrase ‘Hulk hate puny
Banner!’
During the Hulkbuster scene, the Hulk smashes
into a “Crawford” food truck.
The name Crawford is likely a reference to
Dr Geoffrey Crawford, a physics professor
who was Bruce Banner’s mentor before he
turned into the Hulk-like beast Ravage and
became the Hulk’s enemy.
When Bruce Banner hulks out after Scarlet
Witch messes with his mind, Tony Stark in
his Hulkbuster suit tries unsuccessfully to
bring Banner back by hammering the Hulk’s
head while repeating the words “go to sleep,
go to sleep”.
That was a very Tony Stark interpretation
of the lullaby Black Widow used to talk the
Hulk back down to being Bruce Banner at the
start of the movie.
And it’s an interesting role reversal from
The Avengers movie where the Hulk roared at
Stark to bring him back to consciousness after
he fell back to earth through the portal.
Oh, and it also calls to mind the scene where
the Hulk repeatedly smashes Loki into the
floor of Stark Towers in the first Avengers
movie.
During the Hulkbuster scene, the way the Hulk
punches and smashes Iron Man as they blast
up the side of a skyscraper is a call-back
with a twist to the first Avengers movie where
the Hulk saved Iron Man as they moved down
the side of a skyscraper after Iron Man fell
out of the wormhole.
Remember that powerfully comic moment during
the Battle Of New York when Hulk punched Thor
from the side, sending him flying off screen?
Well, Age Of Ultron gives that a twist during
Iron Man’s battle with the Hulk. This time
we see Stark in his Hulkbuster suit punch
the Hulk from the side, making the Hulk disappear
off screen!
Marvel Studios’ President Kevin Feige has
said there’s a Star Wars easter egg which
involves a character getting an arm or a hand
cut off in all of Marvel's Phase 2 movies.
In the Avengers sequel, not only does Iron
Man’s Hulkbuster shed an arm during his
fight with the Hulk, but arms dealer Ulysses
Klaue also has his arm chopped off by Ultron.
Which is an especially nice touch as Andy
Serkis who plays Klaue is also in Star Wars:
The Force Awakens!
While we’re on the subject of Andy Serkis’s
character, did you notice the document on
Klaue that the Avengers consult in the movie?
Well, that revealed that he was hired to kill
T’Chaka, the leader of the African nation
Wakanda, to ensure access to the rare metal
Vibranium.
Vibranium is what Captain America’s shield
is made of and what Ultron buys from Klaue
in this movie.
T’Chaka was the father of T’Challa aka
the current Black Panther, who we’ll meet
in Captain America: Civil War before he returns
in his own movie in 2018.
So, it looks likely we’ll see Serkis back
on screen as Klaw, the villainous enemy of
the Black Panther, just as he is in the comics.
In the salvage yard where Ulysses Klaue is
based, there’s a ship called HMS Churchill,
named after the British wartime Prime Minister
who took over from Neville Chamberlain during
the Second World War.
Chamberlain claimed to have brought “Peace
For Our Time” by arranging a peace treaty
with Hitler, which failed less than a year
later leading to World War Two.
Tony Stark slightly misquotes the phrase as
“peace in our time” to justify his creation
of Ultron, and Ultron later repeats these
words himself.
When Captain America says to Tony Stark, ‘earth’s
mightiest heroes – they pulled us apart
like cotton candy’, it’s a nice nod to
the fact the Avengers are labelled the ‘Earth’s
Mightiest Heroes’ in the comics, and to
Marvel’s animated TV series, The Avengers:
Earth’s Mightiest Heroes!’, which ran
for two seasons from 2010.
In the movie, Helen Cho is a renowned geneticist
and ally of the Avengers.
But in the comics, she’s known as the mother
of teenage genius Amadeus Cho, who’s often
featured in stories alongside the Hulk and
Hercules, and from December 2015 is the lead
character in Marvel’s Totally Awesome Hulk
series.
When Tony Stark sifts through his AI chips
to find a replacement for JARVIS, the one
he picks is marked FRIDAY, which is a reference
to the AI programme that Stark created in
the comics to act as his secretary.
Also, Stan Lee sometimes referred to 1960s
Marvel secretary Flo Steinberg as their ‘gal
Friday’.
There are also at least 2 other chips that
Tony Stark doesn’t choose. One is marked
JOCASTA, who in the Marvel comics was a robot
created by Ultron as a mate.
The second chip that Tony doesn’t use is
only shown in part, but looks like it could
be labelled "TADASHI".
Tadashi was Hiro's older brother and the creator
of Baymax in Disney’s Big Hero 6, which
was inspired by the Marvel comics of the same
name.
It’s interesting that there are also lots
of Iron Man references in Big Hero 6.
For example, Baymax’s first flight is reminiscent
of Tony Stark’s test flight in the first
Iron Man movie.
And, in the SanFransokyo Nerd Lab, there’s
a cat wearing flying boots a la Iron Man,
a robot assistant that resembles Stark’s
robot helper Dum-E, a student who obviously
modelled his facial hair on Tony Stark’s,
and what looks like an arc reactor!
And it’s also possible that the Big Hero
6 nod continues in the Hulkbuster scene where
we see the Hulk and Hulkbuster’s fist bump
send a shockwave through the streets.
Ok, so it wasn’t exactly the same as the
fist bumps between Baymax and Hiro in Big
Hero 6.
But, it is interesting that the Vice President
of Production at Disney Interactive Studios
has called Baymax the “Hulk meets Iron Man”,
which is what we see in that Age Of Ultron
scene!
Fox may have the movie rights to Marvel’s
X-Men, but that didn’t stop Age Of Ultron
giving a cheeky nod to the mutant superheroes
after Hawkeye’s motivational speech to Scarlet
Witch, who in the comics has mutant powers
and parentage herself.
As Hawkeye leaves Scarlet Witch to fight in
the Battle Of Sokovia, we see a brief shot
of his hand, out of which seem to pop some
Wolverine-style claws.
However, they’re actually three sets of
arrows that the bowman’s readying to battle
some bots.
The SHIELD tech who refused to launch the
Insight helicarriers in Captain America: The
Winter Soldier has a brief cameo in Age of
Ultron.
And like in The Winter Soldier where he was
saved by SHIELD Agent 13 Sharon Carter, in
this movie it’s former members of SHIELD
Maria Hill and Nick Fury who save him from
being attacked by one of Ultron’s robots.
The incredible circle shot that showed the
Avengers ready to take on the aliens in the
Battle Of New York is revisited in Age Of
Ultron’s epic final battle against Ultron
and his drones in Sokovia.
Ultron fires on the Hulk from his plane during
the Battle Of Sokovia, which leads to the
Hulk leaping on to the plane and throwing
its pilot, Ultron, down to the ground.
This is a nice call-back to the first Avengers
movie where a pilot also fired on the Hulk
while he was on the helicarrier which caused
the Hulk to jump on to the plane and throw
out the pilot.
As the flying Sokovia starts to fall to the
ground, Vision comes in and saves Scarlet
Witch in a nice little nod to the comics where
Vision and Scarlet Witch marry.
In Marvel's Ultimates comics, Quicksilver
and Scarlet Witch share an incestuous relationship
and actors Elizabeth Olsen and Aaron Taylor-Johnson
decided to play a little with that idea so
in Age of Ultron you'll often see them close
together and holding hands.
The superhero team’s famous comic book catchphrase,
‘Avengers Assemble!’, never made it into
the first movie.
And at the end of Age Of Ultron, Captain America
opens his mouth to address the new Avengers,
but all he gets to say is ‘Avengers’ before
the camera cuts to the credits as his mouth
forms what looks like the letter ‘a’!
Funnily enough, Joss Whedon did use the famous
phrase in season 4 episode 1 of Buffy The
Vampire Slayer when Xander talks about getting
the team together.
Speaking of Buffy The Vampire Slayer, Whedon
included a blink-and-you’ll-miss-it easter
egg to his Buffy spin-off show Angel during
Thor’s visions of Asgard.
In the archways, there are three men wearing
masks – one is a wolf, one is a ram, and
the other is a hart or deer.
On Angel, Wolfram & Hart is a law firm and
front for a trio of demons called the Wolf,
the Ram, and the Hart.
There’s also a wink to Whedon’s Firefly
TV series too.
When the Avengers are in the Quinjet after
the Hydra raid, Tony Stark asks JARVIS to
take the wheel, and then we see a “Jarvis
is my co-pilot" sticker on the cockpit dash.
That’s a nod to Firefly in which Wash is
the pilot of the spaceship Serenity and a
reference to the popular car license plate
frames and stickers which include the words
‘Wash is my co-pilot.’
Age Of Ultron also sets up some of the background
for Captain America: Civil War, including
the conflicting philosophies and burgeoning
opposition between Cap and Iron Man.
First, there’s Stark’s words early on
that Cap is the boss while ‘I just pay for
everything, design everything, and make everyone
look cooler’.
Then, there’s Cap and Stark’s clash over
the “suit of armour around the world”
issue. Stark deliberately hides his Ultron
plans, only sharing them with his Science
Bro, Banner.
Also, while Stark is worried the Avengers
won’t be able to deal with another alien
invasion, Cap takes a different position:
that they’ll win or lose together.
Oh, and of course, Cap, Scarlet Witch and
Quicksilver all unite to try and stop Stark’s
AI project.
And don’t forget the exchange between Stark
and Cap while they’re chopping wood at Hawkeye’s
house. Stark says, ‘I don’t trust a guy
without a dark side’, to which Cap replies,
‘Let’s just say you haven’t seen it
yet.’
By the way, that next Captain America movie
is inspired by the Marvel comics crossover
storyline, Civil War.
In the mid-credits scene, we see Thanos put
on the Infinity Gauntlet and say ‘Fine,
I’ll do it myself.’
Which sets us up nicely for the Avengers:
Infinity War Parts 1 & 2 in which it looks
like Thanos is going to stop relying on others
like Loki to do his dirty work for him and
start kicking ass and taking Infinity Stones
himself!
Thanos’ gauntlet is similar to the one in
Odin’s vault in the first Thor movie, however
this one is for a left hand and has no Infinity
Stones in it yet.
Indeed, Kevin Feige has confirmed there are
2 different gloves in the MCU.
Thanos is the MCU’s big bad. He’s the
‘someone’ who’s ‘been playing an intricate
game and has made pawns of’ the Avengers,
to quote Thor from the end of Age of Ultron.
Not that Thor knows it’s Thanos who’s
the puppet-master at that point.
But thanks to the vision he has, Thor does
know about the incredible, potentially destructive
power of the 6 Infinity Stones.
So far, only 4 stones have appeared in the
MCU: the yellow Mind Stone, the purple Power
Stone, the red Reality Stone, and the blue
Space Stone.
That means, at some point in the movies running
up to the Infinity Wars, we should see the
Soul Stone and the Time Stone appear.
Now, let me know in the comments below: What
other easter eggs and references did you spot
in Avengers: Age Of Ultron?
If you enjoyed this video, do please share
it, hit the thumbs-up button and subscribe
for my things you didn't know videos, as well
as movie reviews and interviews.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!